what's your seven just moving in now
under-fire
it's been almost nine years the original
Gears of War was released on the xbox
360 a game that would sell over 3
million copies in 10 weeks and become
fastest selling video game that year
years also won plenty of awards
including gamespot's game of the year
the game eventually had three sequels
all of which focus on at least one of
the characters from the beloved Delta
Squad the newly revamped gears comes
crashing in with its ultimate edition
boasting 1080p graphics and new content
including five campaign chapters never
released on the xbox but what's the
point in rebooting a series that's less
than ten years old is Microsoft just
trying to get us already and hyped for
gears for or is there something else
that keeps us coming back to that
war-torn city of Jacinto I think there
is for starters the world Sarah feels
eerily close to home a planet that
pretty much looks and feels like
futuristic earth ravaged by war for
resources and i'm not talking about
locusts talking about the pendulum wars
between the coalition of ordered
governments and the union of independent
republics there was a time when humanity
was in a golden age but a need for a new
energy source resulted in a 79 year war
for emotions when cog decided to use the
newly invented hammer of dawn is
basically nuked independent for public
cities just to win a story of
governments fighting over fuel feels
eerily similar to me and it doesn't feel
too far fetched from anyone's
not-too-distant future it paints a good
picture of the stranded and the
politically cited we can really start to
emphasize some of the heartbreaking
people we meet along the way
the setting is important to
understanding the war but it's also
incredibly symbolic to what's happening
to humanity the golden age is given us
gorgeous buildings for people to learn
and grow these buildings were are
ravaged from 79 year war but shortly
after piece was made between governments
then Sarah was attacked by the new
threat locusts who came under the earth
with no intention of living together
after emergence day we get the
neverending war that is the setting for
Gears the environments are typically
something that used to be so beautiful
something picturesque now scarred by the
ravages of war broken down government
buildings evacuated thrash ball arenas
destroyed parks and empty intersections
the beauty is a reminder that what was
is no longer in a world desperate to
heal still surrounded by death and
destruction all that thoughtfulness
really transcends into the gameplay as
well the environments aren't just
backgrounds for your fights they are
interwoven with how you'll strategically
take out your enemies there's a lot to
credit here including a deaf blend of
Resident Evil 4 is over the shoulder
perspective that's become so iconic with
the series mixed with a heavy focus on
cover-based shooting which was inspired
by killswitch a game that was made back
in 2003 by
this tactical focus encourages the
player to look at the layout of the land
and then use it to their advantage like
moving cars to keep out of the line of
fire and not hitting gas tanks you can
keep a line of separation between you
and your enemy if you press your luck
too much you'll get the dreaded crimson
omen letting you know that you need to
find cover and if you don't you'll be
incapacitated and a nearby friend will
have to revive you fight through the
pain now the ability to be revived by
your teammates whether AI or co-op human
it's nothing new but over the course of
the campaign it forces you to operate
not as individuals but as a unit and
what sticks with you is just how close
you end up getting to Marcus Dom full
and bared you originally meet Marcus
Fenix in prison for years after
abandoning his post protect his dad
Marcus rien lists and gears to help the
war effort joining the Delta Squad and
his best friend Dominic Dom Santiago
also on the team is the smart aleck
Damon Baird you're paired yeah that's
right [ __ ] question is who are you
and then just a few short moments later
you need the king of thrash ball himself
Augustus Cole train and right then from
the beginning you get a sense of
camaraderie from this ragtag group of
soldiers that don't always get along all
of them have unique personalities they
all deal with success and failure
differently Marcus is more of a serious
guy and Dom is taking more of a
supportive role Cole is super positive
and Baird is now this really this really
sucks he's Baird and all of them feel
real when you into the world of Sarah
and fighting alongside your friends the
entire story of gears is one of love and
loss success and tragedy beauty and
destruction it's a complicated balance
of happiness and sad
like when you find cog tags of a fallen
soldier it's a story that reminds us how
fragile we are but there are moments as
a group we can accomplish great things
playing the original gears again can
feel haunting knowing what we know your
moments is success like when you get the
liver and successfully through a horde
of krill still feel great it's a
reminder that we're in a moment in time
that nothing lasts forever the Gears of
War franchise earned its fandom a
reputation by creating world that felt
raw real a universe that seemed
plausible conflict that felt close to
home and a team of people that you could
fight alongside of through it all you
can relate to gears making it much more
than just a simple cover based shooter
the story that sticks with you and I
can't wait to play it again
they're turning [ __ ]